warning loud noises and jump-scares
what kind of shitty intro is that
honestly here we go I'm playing as far
as I possibly could from the screen
because I know I know by now the games
they're gonna jump in my face alright I
know the games by now I know how it
works oh I played so many [ __ ] horror
games I know how they work Annette
you're gonna jump scare me right in the
face five nights at Freddy's ah I've
seen it all before
but guess what I don't know this way you
can't jump scare me in my face [ __ ]
oh god I was supposed to read wasn't I
let's actually get into this hello
please forgive me I was in a hurry and
couldn't wait for you to arrive
thank you so much for taking the cake a
lot of people turned me down because
they believe the place is haunted
can you believe that my grandpa is
already asleep he is a heavy sleeper so
he probably won't wake up during the
night but it's best to have you in there
just in case he needs help go into the
bathroom or something the wires in the
house are very old and need to be
replaced
I created lightning devices I mean
flashlights you made [ __ ] flashlights
if for some reason when I your devices
gives you an error you can use their
computer on the kitchen counter
signed Robert alright here we go whoa
whoa what the [ __ ] oh this is creepy
hold the right mouth as a discharge
device
woo this is very creepy okay oh my god
so you click to move around the house a
point-and-click horror game but it's
fast paced so I just have to make sure I
keep all the devices charged and then B
is here Hey are you there
it's a true Sophie's really in the house
oh man I wish I could be there this is
really [ __ ] cool we got to get to D
station though my dick okay we got a
really [ __ ] hurry up - oh God
D station is [ __ ] running out fast
please speedy station oh oh D my D I
can't [ __ ] see anything I swear to
god I can't tell the [ __ ] stations
apart mate oh god B is running out fast
that B station was right there what are
you doing me nope ah oh god it went
wrong I went wrong mom forgive me
oh god it's so close here what just
happen
we're fine we're fine we're fine we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine that was the
[ __ ] beat I ran right past it god
damn oh so focused that's never a good
thing that's never ever a good thing
okay we want to go straight here and
then D station charge tidy up baby Oh
feels good every time we got this bros
easy oh my god I never played it easier
her gaming my laugh I can't even Netflix
and chill with this [ __ ] lightning Oh
Jim oh oh oh oh oh hey ho hey ho hey ho
damn it's so subtle police don't
jump-scare me they said there was Jim
scarce but I have yet to see propper Jim
scam alright see station it's just nine
[ __ ] p.m. well I'm gonna be a super
great shape when I'm done with this
because goddamn I have to run up and
down the stairs what the [ __ ] was that
Sam
they hit my hand
ow I hit my hand a [ __ ] / listen I may
have screamed like a little [ __ ] but I
ain't no [ __ ] alright I screamed
because a girl screamed and I had to out
scream her I am a man [ __ ] cool
alright I don't scream like a [ __ ]
little [ __ ] that was a fake scream yeah
PewDiePie just fake screams for views
that was it I was being cool on the
inside like this on the outside that's
another [ __ ] story maybe I should go
to the kitchen maybe that's my problem
Oh Jeff no defeat that jab Lafitte you
wanna [ __ ] I'm gonna beat this [ __ ]
game at its own game my hand still hurts
our checkpoints checkpoints at 10:00
p.m. all right we're fine
the [ __ ] is this Oh Jeff blood oh my god
what the [ __ ] is this game why do I
still do this five years of this five
years I'm not joking it my heart hurts
one day it's gonna and I'm gonna go to
the hospital and I'm gonna fill myself
doing it and it's gonna get a lot of
[ __ ] Muse gets I feel great I am not
scared I said me is it hot in here am i
sweating can someone put on a fan what
the [ __ ] is that
the [ __ ] come from the Saline
holy [ __ ] sophie is the swell [ __ ]
roommate man that [ __ ] [ __ ] I feel
awesome
this is fine guys we're gonna make it to
7:10 p.m. we got this I don't care if
you're crying Sophie hi oh you thought
you everybody's gonna go oh oh oh I feel
like I'm sweating a little bit
[ __ ] sake not this again
don't be I swear to god Sophie why does
it sound like a [ __ ] oh god damn it
full of shame [ __ ] you hey Sophie this
is you alright
ah oh my god [ __ ] you think a duck is
[ __ ] soft I need some motivational
music right
oh it's turning you on [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
I was Sophie's curse leave it like if
you enjoyed this video if you enjoyed it
leave a like I upload a video every
Wednesday subscribe for more drama
brofist oh my god he was wait oh but we
got the flashlight alright we're gonna
go back now
gotta go back to bed don't attack me